it's that time of the year again
where more than half of the shows that
greg watches
are not nominated you have good taste
although i'm seeing here on this little
thumbnail pick moff gideon
and regina king from watchmen so hey
there's at least
two shows here right hey let's see what
else is in store today we're gonna react
to the emmys nomination list
i love reacting to these because i'm
like hmm
i don't uh i haven't seen this one it's
all gonna be biased
hoping uh uh the one that's gonna win is
the one i've seen that's that's how i'm
gonna operate all day today
a lot of speculation that's pretty crazy
though if mandalorians got some
nominations
yeah it's been making the splash in
terms of the news anyway everybody
didn't expect it
ah one day a marvel show will get a
nomination we'll see
yeah i hope this one's online i hope
this one's like all via zoom that way
it's even more boring than it usually is
yeah with no host
no host let's do it all right 2020 emmy
award nominations all right outstanding
drama series
better call you're winning already
hell yeah killing it awesome
the crown the handmaid's tale killing
eve the mandalorian ozark man i've been
hearing
so much all these shows that people have
messaged me personally
of have you started this yet it's ozark
is the one the number one show
recommended to me
stranger things and succession i wanted
i was planning on starting up succession
yesterday but then i just continued rick
and morty
we'll have to talk later do you have a
pick for who might win this i don't know
who might win it i'm going to stick to
only what i want to win
i want better call saul to win i think
it doesn't get the recognition it
deserves
i don't know the nominations i'm this is
the first time i'm just a reaction to it
and uh aria seahorn on better call saul
is one of the best performances on
television hands down
i put out on twitter a while ago like i
really hope she gets an emmy win one day
or a golden globe win and the one that
just aired was its penultimate season
and the show is
absolutely incredible so i'm hoping
better call saul win so it could get
some more recognition and more people
watching it yeah that's that's my hope
somehow i feel like succession might
take it just because that's the show
i've heard the most about this year but
i mean mandalorian
outstanding comedy series here we go
curb your enthusiasm
are you dead to me okay i haven't seen
dead to me insecure
yeah shit's creek a show i just can't
seem to get into
the good place yeah the kaminsky method
marvelous miss maisel and hey that's
awesome
what we do in the shadows yeah it's a
hard category
i don't think kirby enthusiasm will win
i don't either
but that's the one i want to win i mean
there are so many good picks in here i
would be happy with an insecure shit's
creek a good place or a what we do in
the shadows
what we do has gotten a lot of attention
and a lot of love and a lot of boost
from that movie
although good plays having ended big
deal of a show right now and also
insecure is having a renaissance so i
don't know
i think it'll be a toss-up between
insecure and marvelous miss maisel
the kaminsky method
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series
all right here we go christina applegate
for dead to me rachel brosnan
for marvelous mrs maisel linda cardinale
dead to me this dead to me show must be
pretty great
people love it it's been recommends the
comedy that keeps being recommended to
me catherine o'hara for shit's creek
is array for insecure and tracy ellis
ross for blackish
you never know with these emmys right
has rachel i feel like rachel brosnan's
one
before maybe you know i think with the
spotlight on black lives matter in the
past year
this is one of those situations where i
feel like you got to keep in mind i'm
coming
strictly from a point of view of white
people
i've never seen any of these shows is
what i'm coming from
i've seen more of these shows than the
dramas actually i'm coming from the
angle of i know how the internet is
yeah well and to be fair like insecure
has been around for four seasons now and
has been holding it down with quality
so i know i'm just saying that what the
way internet works
is a lot of the time if a black person
wins
especially now people will be like oh
it's political
but then there'll be a lot of people who
will come to the defense like no this
person actually deserved it because they
were [ __ ] amazing
you know yeah hey man i would be totally
super psyched for issa rae or insecure
or both i'm just noticing there's a
quite a mix here
of white and black shows oh they're
trying to woke up my emmys right yeah
i'm just that's what i'm noticing
your politics out my emmys like i said
i i'm just talking about how the
internet tends to react to things i
have no dog in this fight outstanding
lead actor in a comedy series
anthony anderson for blackish don
cheadle for black monday
ted danson for the good play michael
douglas for the kaminsky method
eugene wow shit's creek is getting a lot
of love
rammy yousef for remy i've heard a lot
of great stuff about rami i feel like
that could maybe clinch it it's a good
video
i love when people hit me up because i'm
like oh man every year i've been
harassed
and i'm like i've heard good things
about a lot of things
all right i'm gonna throw my hat in the
ring here four um i've heard nothing but
amazing things about blackish so i'm
going with anthony anderson
he deserves it i mean i'm not really
familiar with remy youssef but everyone
else here has gotten a lot of
recognition for their work in the past
and don cheadle an oscar-nominated actor
yeah let anthony anderson have it ted
dance has been around forever
come on why not outstanding lead actress
in a drama series jennifer aniston will
not win
olivia coleman for the crown maybe maybe
wins
killing eve my god that's a popular show
i think laura linney will have it
for ozark yeah not sandra well killing
eve that's toughy because sandro and
jody comer might cancel each other out
yeah exactly um and then zendaya zendaya
wait no no i give it to zendaya because
you're trying to get young people to
watch the show that's true
and i heard nothing but euphoria talk
for that two weeks the show had
premiered
yeah yeah you get zendaya to win oh man
you got young people who are actually
watching the emmys yeah man get that
spider-man crap
outstanding lead actor in a drama series
jason
batman for ozark possibly sterling k
brown for this is us possibly steve
carrell for the morning show
probably not brian cox for succession
billy porter for pose jeremy strong for
succession uh i'm gonna give it to steve
carrell for this one
uh just because he has no chance of
winning
i'm with you i support this message it
sounds like a blast
outstanding reality competition program
the masked singer
oh hell yeah yes that's what i'm talking
about
nailed it nailed it i love that show
rupaul's drag race top chef and the
voice
all right i think the mass singer
singer's
got it's such a phenomenon it has to
it's a meme it's the best
nailed it is the same episode every time
and it's great every time but it is
like the same thing every single time
yeah
which i mean congrats for making it into
these nominations
outstanding lead actor in a limited
series or movie
jeremy irons for watchmen hell yeah
that's what i'm talking about ozymandias
hugh jackman and bad education
true stories of corruption that's what
i'm talking about
paul mescal normal people yeah i've seen
that
jeremy pope for hollywood oh [ __ ] drove
there recently
mark ruffalo i know this much is true
i've seen the billboard
i don't think jeremy irons will win even
though that's the one i want to win
because that's the only show i've seen
here
well you know mark ruffalo's playing two
people so it's oh [ __ ]
easily harder oh [ __ ] so it's got to be
him so
if he could win for that then you're
winning for like two people
yeah they better give him two trophies
or maybe he can get nominated for
supporting actor as well
outstanding lead actress in a limited
series or movie cate blanchett for mrs
america
shira has for unorthodox regina king for
watching
okay now out of anyone i'm excited for
watchmen because
is this the first comic book series
that's getting a lot of recognition for
the first time
i feel like in this caliber yeah because
i'm constantly complaining about how
there's so many comic book shows
with emmy golden globe worthy
performances that just don't get
recognition
and regina king and watchman is one of
the performances that absolutely
deserves it
so i feel like for my love for that show
and
for my love for that performance of hers
i would love for her to win
but you know it could be cate blanchett
i mean there's always a reason to give
cate blanchett an award i guess
i love how like all these actresses of
color and there's cate blanchett i would
i would love it if it was
oh wait no shira haas is what is she
she's israeli that
that's that's kind of not white okay
well cate blanche has the widest one i
would love it if she won just to just to
upset a real one yeah there you go
i love how political people get about
these ceremonies
so silly outstanding supporting actor in
a drama series
giancarlo esposito for gus hell yeah
wow that's a lot of people man they
don't have a limit do they
no and not even to the show you can
nominate for because nicholas braun
karen colgan and matthew mcfadyen are
all getting succession nominations
that's too much bradley whitford for the
handmaid's tale
billy crudup and mark duploss for the
morning show
jeffrey wright for westworld damn it's
on that show we've only seen season one
i know
one day i'll take an interest again has
john carlo ever won
i don't know i mean he's a vet and he's
been around so i feel like if he hasn't
now would be
the perfect time especially because you
know we can all go you just probably
should have won during breaking bad but
uh you know better call so it's still
good yeah i mean he gets much
more of uh three-dimensional performance
to explore
in better call saul then hell yeah then
uh than you did in breaking bad and
obviously he's incredible in it
outstanding supporting actress in a
drama series
of course big little lies ooh laura dern
and meryl streep
wow fiona shaw for killing eve
oh my favorite show oh julia garner
which one ozark are killing eve
both of them definitely mine too both
sarah snook got a nomination for
succession i don't care anymore i want
her to
win helena bonham carter the crown yes
suck it tim burton samira wiley
the handmaid's tale and tandy newton for
westeros i would love if if hell and
bottom corner won
and then said that on screen suck it tim
tandy newton actually had a wonderful
like really like a long interview
i talked about so much in the industry
of course every headline was continued
it talks about working with tom cruise
that's like the very goodness very end
of that article
over a decade but the majority of it is
is a real
in-depth introspective very personal
vulnerable interview about some truly
harsh experiences
and then it ends with tom cruise
man i love that tandy newton so if she
had an experience with tom
that's what i need to read about yeah
man outstanding supporting actor in a
comedy series andrea brauer brooklyn
nine-nine
mahershala ali for rami blade keenan
thompson
hell yeah dude he's holding the ford
down there is he the longest running
cast member now
i think so daniel levy uh levees sorry
shit's creek
william jackson harper for the good
place alan arkin and the kaminsky method
white dudes
sterling k brown and tony chalu for the
m wow sterling k brown's nominee for
two separate shows he's in everything
now he's the mr
it he's a great he's a great actor he
deserves a recognition
outstanding supporting actress in a
comedy series
betty gilpin for glow she's good on glow
man she's always getting nominated
yvonne
orgy for insecure yeah um i'm not sure
or he or g not entirely i'll have to
watch her stand-up special
it's a bummer actually because i'm a fan
of her character on the show i should
know
kate mckinnon saturday night live and
cecily strassely strong
annie murphy for shits creek darcy
cardin for the good place
alex borstein and marin hinkle for the
marvelous miss maisel
yeah that show is not as good as
everyone makes it out to be now
disclaimer i've never seen it but
outstanding supporting unlimited series
sure it's a great show guys dylan
mcdermott
hollywood engine parsons killing it
titus burgess for the unbreakable kimmy
schmidt kimmy versus the reverend is
that the choose your own adventure
yaya abdulmatude watchman
as well as jovan adepo and louis
junior damn damn watchman's getting a
lot of g
no tim blake nelson that's a surprise
too but i don't know
he like was the main supporting actor
in that show and he is if anybody i mean
not
not to go up for bat for white actors or
whatever because they don't need help
but like
i mean john stop just be honest i tim
like nelson's been holding it down as a
terrific character actor for
so long yeah nomination i think
especially for his
you know stature on the show would have
been nice i mean i think
yaya and jovan yeovan i'm going to say
louis gossett jr his character is
wonderful in the series
like all three of these characters are
exceptionally
important in the show i would say that
between the three the one i would swap
out would be
lewis i just felt like tim blake nelson
had a lot more he had to
challenge himself emotionally for in
that show but i'm racist now
and you're ageist you suck man i hate
you that's just what happened
outstanding supporting actress in a
limited series or movie
holland taylor from hollywood and bill
and ted face the music
uzo aduba for mrs america
as well as character actress margot
martindale
and character actors tracy oldman
awesome tony collette unbelievable you
know what's unbelievable
no hereditary nod nah you know what else
is unbelievable
i've never heard of unbelievable yeah i
mean i don't know what the hell they're
talking about
gene smart for watchmen yeah she's great
in that
yeah good call she should win worthy
nods all
outstanding variety talk series the
daily show with trevor noah
full frontal with samantha bee jimmy
kimmel levay i'm surprised that jimmy
kimmel's nominated after all the
backlash that happened recently with him
you know they're trying to prove that
they can keep everybody's thoughts in
mind so they're going to get one
controversial pick
way down in the deep cut categories last
week tonight with john oliver
or the late show with stephen colbert
you know i think
trevor noah's got a shot um but you know
john oliver's show has not dipped in
quality
even during the cove attack it was kind
of weird at first with no audience but
yeah it's still still really enjoyable
yeah a sunny variety sketch series a
black lady sketch show
drunk history saturday night i would
love it
if drunk history has it ever won i'm not
sure but i feel like this would be the
perfect year to do it because i think
snl tends to win well it has like such a
big cultural impact drunk history
yeah and it's grown like out of the
reaches of the internet on to like a
full-fledged yeah tv things like that
exactly
i would love to see them win outstanding
hosts for a reality or reality
competition program amy poehler
for making it nicole byer for nailed it
she better win
definitely bobby burke queer eye rupaul
for rupaul's drag race
barbara corcoran for shark tank
and padma lakshmi top chef hells yeah
talk chef oh man it better be nicole
buyer
definitely homebuyer he just earned it
and then some
nailed it outstanding guest actor in a
drama series oh
andrew scott black mirror from uh he's
the moriarty guy he was in the episode
where he takes the kid hostage right
yeah from sherlock and various other
things
oh yeah it's not the best episode of
that season but he's good in it i will
say that's interesting
james cromwell for succession giancarlo
for the mandalorian
damn two this is john carlo's year what
if he wins both
i don't think he'll win for the
mandalorian
his appearance is great but i think
season two he'll probably have a better
shot
i think season two would have a better
shot and i feel like not that's the same
category but
let's face it the one the performance he
gives him better calls all is much more
of a fleshed out powerhouse performance
there's more depth and like to explore
on screen with these other
performances here like jason bateman
yeah
yeah martin short in the morning show
iran cephas
jones outstanding guest actress in a
drama series
cicely tyson for how to get away with
murder oh damn
maybe i think my pops might have worked
with her on that show at one point in
time so i'm rooting for her
automatically
laverne cox orange is the new black
cherry
jones and harriet walter for succession
alexis bedell
hey look at her getting some recognition
yeah and felicia rashad
this is us someone from succession has
to take it succession's gonna win some
stuff tonight
outstanding guest actor in a comedy
series
fred willard for modern family
dev patel for modern love too modern
let's go back to saturday night live
with brad pitt adam driver or eddie
murphy
oh man adam driver driver was hysterical
last episode he was the funniest one
yeah yeah he was right
i'm not sure i remember many sketches of
the other two unfortunately but adam
driver stole the show he saved like
so many of those sketches could have
been really bad if random driver didn't
deliver the way he did
luke kirby for the marvelous miss mazel
gonna have to check that show out
i just want adam driver to win for that
i do too just because he's the only
one in the past year who sketches i
revisit on youtube
i can't get enough of them they're so
funny standing guest actress in a comedy
series
angela bassett a black lady sketch show
where is this show aired
i'm not sure i wanna i feel like it's
really like the cast they've been
listening for it just sounds so good
it's hbo it's an hbo show
well we have no excuse now maya
sorry oh you're good this i care about
how we do the order maya rudolph
and phoebe waller bridge as well for snl
and maya rudolph again for the go
uh good plays i would say i love when
that happens and then they don't win
i know this is just a double burn or if
she does win you're not
good enough you had two chances what's
your excuse watch them both i would love
it though if she does win for one
because then that's definitive proof
that one is better than the other
uh wanda sikes for marvelous miss maisel
for the politician i didn't even realize
she was on that show oh my god we're
we're finally at the end
and outstanding this list limited
series little fires everywhere mrs
america
this show i've never heard of
unbelievable or unorthodox
never heard of them or a watchman
watchmen better win
watchmen i think you all watch men ought
to win
all right guys well hooray for watchmen
and the mandalorian and better call
are you pleased only three i've actually
watched completely
leave your picks in the comment box
below and stranger things
yeah why not but like yeah i mean i
think it's exciting that mandalorian and
watchmen in terms of shows that you
don't really expect to hear getting
nominated actually get nominated
yes they're two shows that absolutely
deserve it well yeah they're remarkable
in their own ways and especially for
watchmen i mean there's a lot going on
that's super relevant and it's got the
comic book stuff backing it and then
with mandalorian you have
just this huge return to form for a
franchise that demonstrates a whole lot
of filmmaking prowess and whatnot and
stuff so even if it's not like the most
deep show there's still a lot of quality
there and i'm happy to see both of them
get recognized along with all these
other
mainstays i can't wait for them to not
win all the awards because you know how
it goes
succession's going to sweep they're
going to get your clicks just because
they got nominated
am i cynical towards these awards
ceremonies no
no not at all not at all they're the
greatest most important things in the
world
guys subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell tell us in the
comments
how much you love the emmys and which
ones are you hoping wins put your picks
down below
last but not least
today i'd like to shout out our homeboy
jean jeter from jean jeter tv
tyrone magnus has been reacting to his
videos lately as well and you know
with the emmys what do we love seeing
people do fashion stuff
right that's always the talk of the town
look how stupid she looks look how great
she looks all those guys look the same
who wore it better jean has a video out
called try on fashion hall christine
summer collection
i don't really watch that many try on
videos but i could watch
christine try on all these collection
items any day
anytime i have yeah john has this on
repeat whenever he's exporting a video
so guys make sure to go
check out jean jeter's youtube channel
thanks gene for being here you crazy son
of a bee